สวัสดีค่ะครูชิสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนเช่น
กันค่ะก็วันนี้นะคะครูชิกับครูบีเรามาเจอ
กันในห้องเรียน comprehensible ไยค่ะห้อง
เรียนภาษาไทยด้วยกันฟังอืมนะแล้วก็วันนี้
ครูบีแล้วก็ครูชิเรามาเจอกันในวันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันนี้วันอังคารค่ะอ่าวันอังคารวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 20 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
ครูชิเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะปีพ.ศร่ะคะ
2567 ปีค.ศรอคะ
2024 ค่ะนะฮะวันนี้เป็นวันอังคารที่ 20
กุมภาพันธ์พุทธศักราช 26
17 คริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะนะก็มาเจอกันเนี่ยวันเนี้ยครูชิ
มีเรื่องอะไรมาเล่าให้ครูบีฟังคะวันเนี้ย
ครูชิเเนี่ยมีมีความรู้สึกว่าเวลาที่เรา
ไปดูข่าวหรือฟังข่าวนะคะเกี่ยวกับสิ่งที่
เกิดขึ้นในสังคมไทยบางทีเราเจอข่าวที่เรา
รู้สึกว่ามีคนแบบนี้ด้วยเหรอ
อืแปลว่าูชิเเนี่ยได้ดูแล้วก็ได้ฟัง
เรื่องเนี้ยคือมันเกิดขึ้นในชีวิตของคน
ไทยใช่อ้าแล้วมันเป็นเรื่องอะไรคะเรื่อง
ดีหรือเรื่องไม่ดีครูชิเป็นเรื่องที่รู้
สึกไม่ดีค่ะไม่ดีโชคไม่ดีไปเจอคนไม่ดีอ้า
เรื่องมันมีอย่างนี้คะครูบีอืยังไง
อ่ะก็มีผู้หญิงนะผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายเค้า
กำลังคิดอยากจะแต่งงานกัน
นะผู้หญิงกับผู้ชายกำลังคิดจะแต่งงานเอ้า
อันนี้ก็เป็นข่าวดีเรื่องดีผู้หญิงกับผู้
ชายรักกันอู้วาเลนไทน์จะแตนแทนแทแต่งงาน
ก็ดีนะอืทีเนี้ยเค้าเนี่ยก็มีมีคุณลุงไง
เอออันนี้อันนี้เนี่ยเอ่อไม่ใช่ของผู้ผู้
ชายผู้หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงก็มีพ่ออืแล้วก็
แม่นะค่ะแล้วก็มีพี่ชายพี่ชายของคุณแม่
คุณลุงนะค่ะค่ะคุณลุงก็คิดว่าหลานสาว
เนี่ยกำลังจะแต่งงานอืมใช่มั้ยก็เลยคิด
อยากจะให้เรือเรือนหอเรือนหอก็คือบ้านที่
ให้ 2 คนเนี่ยไปอยู่ด้วยกัน
อ่าว้าวคุณลุงเนี่ยใจดีนะคะอือเอ่าก็คิด
จะให้บ้านเป็นเรือน
หอใช่ค่ะทีนี้ 2 คนนี้ก็เลยคิดอยากจะไปดู
ใช่มั้ยอืคุณคุณลุงเนี่ยซื้อบ้านหลัง
เนี้ยซื้อมานานแล้วค่ะครูบีซื้อมา 32 ปี
แล้ว
โอ้โหนานมากครูชิเข้าอายุครูบี
เลยแต่คุณลุงอ่ะไม่เคยไปอยู่บ้านหลังนี้
ไงไม่เคยมีใครไปอยู่บ้านหลังนี้เลยแต่
ซื้อเอาไว้นานแล้วอืมพอเห็นหลานสาวกำลัง
จะแต่งงานก็เลยคิดอยากจะยกบ้านหลังเนี้ย
ให้เป็นเรือนหอ
โหเพราะว่าเวลาผู้ชายกับผู้หญิงแต่งงาน
กันเนี่ยถ้ามีเรือนหอเป็นบ้านเนี่ยอสบาย
เลยเนาะ
อ่าเพราะว่าบางคนเนี่ยต้องทำงานทำงานทำ
งานเก็บเงินถึงจะสร้างบ้านได้ใช่มยแต่นี่
คุณลุงใจดีมากบอกยกบ้านให้เลยเป็นเรือนหอ
เออเพราะ 2 คนเยค่ะครูบีไปดูบ้านค่ะอืมก็
ตกใจค่ะเอ้าทำไมคะแล้วก็งงเอ้ามีคนน่ะมา
อยู่ที่บ้านเค้าค่ะ
หืบ้านที่ยังไม่มีใครไปอยู่เลยเนี่ยแต่มี
คนเนี่ยเข้ามาในบ้านเค้าแล้วคนที่เข้ามา
เนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนบ้านกูชิจะวาดแบบเป็นแบบ
นี้นะค่ะบ้านมันเหมือนกับเป็นแบบุดแถวอ่ะ
เป็นเป็นทาวน์เฮ้าส์อ่ามันก็จะต่อกันแบบ
เนี้ยครูบีค่ะนะเป็นทาวน์เฮ้าส์เป็นแบบ
หลังๆๆังมันก็จะมีช่วงในซอยที่แบบมันจะ
เป็นซอยที่เชื่อมกันระหว่างระหว่างอาคาร
นี้ใช่มยเ้าจะมีไว้สำหรับให้รถอ่ะเวลาคน
ขับรถใช่มยค่ะจะได้มีแบบกลับรถไงอืมกลับ
รถได้ใช่มั้ยคะอใช่ใช่อันนี้จะเป็นทางตัน
แบบนี้อืม
นะบ้านของเค้าเนี่ยคือบ้านหลังนี้
ค่ะ
อือแต่ปรากฏว่าไอ้ตรงซอยตันเนี่ยค่ะมีคน
เนี่ยมาสร้างเป็นเหมือนกับเพลิงเพลิงแบบ
เนี้ยค่ะแล้วก็มีโต๊ะมีอะไรมาตั้งตรงนี้
ก็เค้าก็จอดรถตรงนี้เ้าจอดรถ
ค่ะอืแล้วตรงเก็จะเป็นเพลิงมีเก้าอี้มีคน
นั่งแล้วตรงเนี้ยถูกทะลุเข้าไปให้เป็นแบบ
เหมือนเหมือนกับ
เป็นเป็นเอ่อประตูอืเ้าพังเข้าไปเป็น
ประตูเลยนะบีอุ้ยอันนี้มันบ้านคนนะคะคือ
เราซื้อไว้เราไม่อยู่แต่ก็เป็นบ้านเราใช่
มยใช่เนี่ยค่ะครูบีอันเนี้ยบ้านของเอ่อ 2
คนที่คิดจะแต่งงานกันนะแล้วคุณลุงให้บ้าน
หลังนี้ค่ะอค่ะแต่เพื่อนบ้านเนี่ยน่าจะ
เป็นบริษัทอืทำเกี่ยวกับเรื่องก่อสร้าง
อะไรเนี่ยแล้วเค้าก็เห็นมั้ยต่อทางเชื่อม
อืมอ๋อต่อทางเชื่อม
ระหว่างเอ่อบ้านตัวเองบ้านตัวเองกับบ้าน
ของคนเนี้ยอืนะตรงตรงนี้ก็ใช้เป็นที่จอด
รถทำเป็นที่ของตัวเองไปเลยค่ะอืมนะคะอ๋อ
เพราะว่าคุณลุงเนี่ยไม่เคยมาบ้านนี้เลย
แต่ซื้อไว้ใช่มั้ยเหใช่ค่ะครูบีเห็น
มั้ยเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยไปถึงก็น่าจะตกใจนะ
เอ้าไหนคุณลุงบอกไอ้นี่ทำไมมีคนมาอยู่อ่ะ
เออแล้วก็กำแพงบ้านบ้านครูบีกำแพงบ้าน
เนี่ยเาก็มาเจาะไงเนี่ยๆๆอันเนี้ยทำ
หลังคาเชื่อมแล้วนะแล้วกำแพงของบ้านบ้าน
ของเขาอ่ะถูกเจาะแบบนี้เลย
ค่ะแล้วก็มีคนเอาประตูมาใส่แล้วข้างใน
เนี่ยทำเหมือนเป็นห้องครัวทำ
อาหาร
เฮ้ยจะมีคนอยู่ 20 ปี 30 ปี 5  50 ปีคน
อื่นก็จะไปเจาะบ้านแล้วเข้าไปอยู่ทำห้อง
ครัวไม่ได้นะคะครูชิก็นั่นน่ะสิคะเค้าก็
ตกใจเค้าก็บอกว่าบ้านหลังเนี้ยเป็นบ้าน
ของเค้านะคุณลุงเค้าเนี่ยให้เค้าเนี่ย
อยากจะมาตกแต่งนะคะเค้าอยากจะมาทำบ้าน
ใหม่ที่นี่นะคะก็ทำเรื่องแล้วก็คุยกันให้
เค้าเนี่ยย้ายออกไปอืมแต่ดูฝั่งฝั่งที่
เข้ามาบุกลุกอ่ะเข้ามาในที่ของคนอื่นเรา
เรียกว่าบุกลุกนะใช่คนที่เข้ามาบุกลุก
บ้านเค้าเนี่ย
อืมก็เหมือนรู้ตัวนะครูบีรู้ตัวยังไงอ่ะ
ูชิรู้ตัวว่าตัวเองผิดไงพอเจ้าของบ้านมา
แล้วเจ้าของบ้านพูดเนี่ยเบอกโอเคโอเค
เดี๋ยวเขาจะเอาของออกไปเค้าเห็นว่าไม่มี
ใครอยู่ก็แค่เจาะประตูอืจริงๆแล้วมัน
เหมือนกำแพงมันจะพังเคพูดแบบนั้นนะเหมือน
กำแพงมันกำลังจะพังเคก็เลยเจาะเป็นประตู
ใส่บานประตูเอาไว้แล้วก็ขอมาทำครัวไง
เพราะเห็นว่าไม่มีใครอยู่ก็แค่มาทาครัวมา
กินอาหารโอ้โหต่อให้บ้านน่ะอยู่เป็นรปีนะ
ครูชิถ้าไม่ใช่บ้านของเราอ่ะเราก็จะไปคิด
คิดเอาเองว่าโอ้ไม่มีคนอยู่ฉันอยากจะไปทำ
อาหารกินที่นี่แค่นี้เองไม่ได้นะ
คะแล้วนี่แบบเจาะประตูเอาเตาแก๊สเอาโต๊ะ
เอาเครื่องปรุงอาหารเนี่ยไปทำในในบ้าน
เค้าเลยอืม
นะแล้วก็เอาของต่างๆเนี่ยไปเก็บไว้ในบ้าน
เค้าที่เกี่ยวกับก่อสร้างอะไรเนี่ยอืพอ
เจ้าของบ้านมาเห็นเจ้าของบ้านก็คุยเก็บอก
โอเคเดี๋ยวเขาจะใช้เวลาย้ายออกไปอืนะคะ
ผ่านไปเค้าเจ้าของ 2 คนนะสามีภรรยาเนี่ย
ก็ไม่สามารถทำบ้านหลังนี้เป็นเรือนหอได้
แล้วนะเพราะว่าจะแต่งงานแล้วเนี่ยทำบ้าน
ไม่ทันแล้วเพราะว่าคนยังอยู่ยังไม่ออกไป
ไงค่ะก็มาคุยกันก่อนใช่มั้ยใช่ตอนแรกผู้
ชายผู้หญิงที่แต่งงานกันเนี่ยก็มาคุยก่อน
ว่าให้ย้ายออกไปก็ก็ไม่ได้คิดไม่ได้คิด
โอ้โหแจ้งตำรวจมาจับเพราะว่าบุกรุกบ้าน
เราอืใช่แล้วพอบอกให้ย้ายออกไปเนี่ยเค้า
ออกมั้ยคะูชิตอนแรกเค้าออกไปนะคะเค้าก็
เอาของเขิงต่างๆออกไปหมดเลยนะคะแล้วแล้ว
เอ่อเจ้าของบ้านน่ะเจ้าของบ้าน 2 สามี
ภรรยาใช่มั้ยตอนนี้เแต่งงานกันแล้วเรา
ต้องไปหาหาบ้านบ้านที่เป็นเรือนหอใหม่ละ
นะคะแต่เค้าก็ยังมาดูบ้านหลังนี้ไงเพราะ
ว่าคุณลุงให้เออก็ต้องมารเค้าเรียกอะไรตก
แต่งใหม่รวทใหม่ใช่มยอ่าทำให้มันสวยๆเขา
ก็ต้องมาดูบ้านหลังนี้ว่าจะเอ๊ะจะทำยังไง
อ่าจะทำยังไงให้สวยๆใช่มยแล้วยังไงอ่ะูชิ
คนที่เข้ามาบุกลุกก็เบอกว่าจริงๆแล้ว
เนี่ยเค้าตั้งใจว่าเห็นไม่มีคนอยู่เตั้ง
ใจจะสึซื้ออยู่แล้วอืตั้งใจจะซื้อต่อจาก
เจ้าของเค้าเข้ามาใช้บ้านหลังเนี้ยอยากจะ
รอเจ้าของมาแล้วก็มาคุยกันเค้าอยากจะซื้อ
บ้านหลังนี้เอ้าอยากจะซื้อบ้านก็ต้องรอ
ค่ะไม่ใช่ไปอยู่บ้านคนอื่นบุกรุกบ้านคน
อื่นไอ้นี่ผิดนะครูชิใช่เอแล้วเาก็บอกว่า
เคอยากจะซื้อด้วยงนสดเลยแต่จะซื้อในราคา
400,000
990,000 บาทโอ้โหนัก
เรียน
490,000 บาทค่ะทำไมซื้อถูกมากคะโอโหคุณ
จะซื้อบ้านในราคา 490,000 บาทอันนี้คุณขอ
ฟรีดีกว่านะคะเอออันเนี้ยเป็นราคาเมื่อปี
2534 ค่ะครูบีอ้าจะราคากี่ปีที่แล้วคุก็
ไม่มีสิทธิ์ไปอยู่บ้านคนอื่นตอนที่คุณยัง
ไม่ได้ซื้อเจ้าของบ้านไม่รู้ว่าคุณบุกรุก
เข้ามาอยู่เจ้าของบ้านไม่รู้ว่าคุณอยากจะ
ซื้อเจ้าของบ้านก็ไม่รู้ด้วยว่าคุณเนี่ย
มาทำอาหารมาทุบกำแพงอันนี้แจ้งตำรวจจับ
เลยนะครูชิเออถ้าเป็นครูบีเนี่ยใช่เออ
ต้องแจ้งเลยค่ะแจ้งตำรวจว่ามีการบุกลุก
ใช่มั้ยแล้วตำรวจจะได้ให้ออกไปใช่มคะเค้า
อ้างว่าบ้านหลังเนี้ยไม่มีคนอยู่เป็นแบบ
เป็น 10 ๆปีแล้วนะคะเป็นบ้านร้างค่ะบ้าน
ร้างก็คือคนซื้อแล้วทิ้งเอาไว้ไม่มีคน
อยูู่ชิคะครูบีเนี่ยเห็นในกรุงเทพฯนะคะ
กูชิมีบ้านร้างเนี่ยโอ้โหเยอะมากแบบเนี้ย
ค่ะเนี่ยบ้านร้างแบบนี้อันนี้น่าจะไม่ใช่
กรุงเทพฯเดี๋ยวเอารูปใหม่คือทุกที่มันจะ
มีบ้านที่ไม่มีคนอยู่เราเรียกบ้านร้างใช่
มั้ยหรือจะเป็นแบบเนี้ยครูชิใช่ครูบีก็
อยากจะถามนะว่าคนที่บุกรุกเนี่ยก็ผิดนะ
อ่าถ้าเป็นบ้านแบบูชิเคยเห็นมยเหมือน
เหมือนบ้านร้างไม่มีคนอยู่ครอบครัวอาจจะ
ตายแล้วอย่างเงี้ยค่ะแล้วแบบเนี่ยแบบ
เนี้ยเดี๋ยวๆนะครูบีให้
อืแล้วครูบีคิดดูอ่ะเค้ามามามามาซ่อมแซม
บ้านหมดน่ะโบ้านจริง
ๆคุณบีคะอันนี้บ้านร้างหรือบ้านผีสบ้าน
ร้างแล้วก็มีผี
เอแนะคะเอ่าทำไมเค้าไม่มาอยู่คะอันนี้ 50
ปี 100 ปี 100 ปีเป็นบ้านร้างคนที่เข้ามา
อยู่นี่ก็บุกรุกเหมือนกันนะูชิเพราะก็มี
เจ้าของใช่อืถูกต้อง
มีคนสร้างบ้านมีเหรอว่าไม่มีเจ้าของเออ
ใครใครใครคะจะไปสร้างบ้านแล้วอ้าใครจะ
อยู่ก็ได้มันไม่ใช่ไงครูบีสร้างบ้านมาอ่า
แล้วอยู่ๆครูบีเเนี่ยซื้อบ้านที่ดินใช่
มั้ยแล้วก็สร้างขึ้นมาแล้วครูบีแตนแนแนๆ
แต่งงานไปอยู่อเมริกาเอ้า 30 ปีใช่มั้ย
อ่า 1 วันครูบีอาจจะกลับมาประเทศไทยแล้ว
ก็
ออบอกให้บ้านน้องสาวก็ได้ให้คุณแม่เออให้
ครูชิก็ได้ใช่มั้ยครูบีบอกโอ้ครูบีรวย
แล้วยกให้กูชิอย่างเงี้ยอเออกูชิถึงจะมี
สิทธิ์มาอยู่ใช่มั้ยใช่แต่คนอื่นจะเข้ามา
อยู่เนี่ยไม่ได้นะผิดนะคะูชิใชู่ชิก็เลย
งงมากว่าเคิดได้อย่างไงว่าบ้านไม่มีคน
อยู่ฉันก็เลยมาอยู่แล้วที่สำคัญเค้าก็มา
แบบมามาทำหลังคาบ้านมาไว้ออ่อเอาของมา
เก็บไว้ในนั้นน่ะค่ะโอ้โหจนเจ้าของเมา
เนี่ยเาก็เลยให้ออกใช่มั้ยเาก็ขนย้ายของ
ออกหมดนะแต่เขาก็พยายามบอกว่าอย่าอย่า
อย่าว่าพี่บุกลุกแต่พี่ตั้งใจจะซื้อบ้าน
พอคุยกันแล้วเนี่ยเสนอราคาเนี่ยไม่น่าสนใ
ใจค่ะอืแล้วก็พูดจาไม่ดีเจ้าของบ้านใช่
มั้ยคนที่เป็นคู่สามีภรรยาที่แต่งงาน
เนี่ยก็เลยบอกว่าไม่ขายนะคะแล้วก็เลยเอา
กุญแจเนี่ยมาล็อคเอาโซ่นะโซ่แกกๆๆแล้วก็
มาล็อคบ้านล็อคทั้งประตูข้างหลังที่เขา
เจาะอ่ะแล้วล็อคข้างในนะไม่ใช่ล็อคข้าง
นอกนะคะโแล้วก็ล็อกหน้าประตูด้วยอ้าก็
บ้านของเค้าไงเออฉันไม่ได้จะขายฉันไม่ได้
อยากขายคุณจะมาบอกฉันจะซื้อก็ฉันไม่ขาย
อ่ะคุณจะมาอยู่ทำไมเออฉันไม่ขายแล้วคุณมา
บุกลุกอยู่ก่อนด้วยมาทำอาหารมาเจาะบ้าน
บ้านพังหมดอันนี้ผิดนะคะต้องเสียเงินให้
ครูบีนะเนี่ยถ้าเป็นบ้านครูบีเเนี่ยครูบี
ไม่โอเคไม่ยอมใชอืใช่ค่ะบีจะไปแจ้งตำรวจ
เลยไปแจ้งความแล้วก็โหไม่ได้ค่ะูชิโกรธนะ
เนี่ยเออแล้วพอคนล็อคกุญแจหมดแล้วนะเค้า
ก็ทิ้งเอาไว้จนกระทั่งแบบไม่ไม่กี่ไม่กี่
วันที่ผ่านมานะในในต้นเดือนเนี้ยเขาคก็ไป
ดูบ้านอีกครั้งนึงค่ะอปรากฏว่าโซ่ที่ล็อค
บ้านน่ะค่ะถูกปัด
อู้ถูกปัดค่ะแล้ว
แล้วคนเดิมเลยค่ะเข้ามาอยู่
หึมีคนมาแบบนี้คนคนที่บุกรุกเนี่ยเหมือน
ไอคิวโอเคมั้ยคะบ้านคนอื่นแต่ยังแบบเค้า
ให้ออกแล้วไม่แจ้งตำรวจจับยังจะไปเอา
เลื่อยตัดโซ่ล็อคบ้านเค้าแล้วเข้าไปอยู่
อีกใช่ค่ะนะคะแล้วก็ที่สำคัญเนี่ยเค้าก็
บอกว่าเค้าก็เคก็เหมือนกับจะสู้อืเขาคบอก
ว่าเค้าเข้ามาอยู่อ่ะเขาคอยู่นานเป็น 10
ปีแล้วที่เขาอยากจะเป็นเจ้าของถ้าอยู่ 10
ปีแล้วเนี่ยจะเป็นเจ้าของได้
โอ้โหงั้นครูบีไปอเมริกา 30 ปีครูชิมา
อยู่บ้านครูบีบุกรุกเข้ามาครูบีไม่ได้
อนุญาตเออครูบีไม่รู้ว่าครูชิเข้ามาอยู่
บ้านครูบีเพราะมาทุบประตูใช่มั้ยเอ้อเอ้อ
แล้วครูครูบีกลับมาจากอเมริกาเอ้าใครมา
อยู่บ้านฉันูชิก็ไม่มีสิทธิ์ค่ะต่อให้ครู
ชิอยู่ 10 ปีเพราะบ้านครูบีครูบีไม่ได้
อนุญาตให้ครูชิเข้ามาอยู่เห็นมั้อแล้ว
แล้วเจ้าของบ้านน่ะเขาก็เลยเถียงค่ะคือพอ
พอมาดูอีกทีเนี่ยตัดโซ่แล้วเนี่ยครูบีก็
มีป้ายค่ะมีป้ายมาแกวนหน้าบ้านอืตอนแรก
เนี่ยจำได้มั้ยมันมันโล่งๆนะตอนนี้มีป้าย
มาหน้าบ้านค่ะอืเขียน
ว่าไก่ตะไก่ตะเกียบทอดน้ำปลาเนี่ยค่ะแล้ว
ก็มีเบอร์โทรศัพท์ติดต่อนะทำเป็นว่าบ้าน
หลังนี้เนี่ยทำเป็นธุรกิจแล้วก็มีจดหมาย
แบบนี้ค่ะมีกระดาษแผ่นนี้ค่ะติดไว้ที่
หน้าบ้านบอกว่าเค้าเนี่ยเข้ามาอยู่มาครอบ
ครองมาอยู่บ้านหลังเนี้ยนาน 10 ปีแล้ว
เค้าเนี่ยเป็นเจ้าของ
โอ้โหอันนี้เค้าพูดกับคนใช่มั้ยคะเค้าน่า
จะบ้านะคะครู
ชิบ้านคนอื่นเข้าไปอยู่จริงๆต้องโดนตำรวจ
จับด้วยนะบุกรุกบ้านคนอื่นอันนี้ขโมยบ้าน
เลยนะครูชิอันนี้ครูบีคิดว่าคนเนี้ยเป็น
ขโมยแต่ไม่ได้ขโมยเงินขโมยโทรศัพท์นะขโมย
บ้านคน
อื่นใช่ครูบีแบบไม่เคยเห็นว่ามีแบบนี้
ด้วยนะใช่ครูบีเคยดูข่าวที่ทีวีครูบีก็
ไม่เคยได้ยินว่าคุณ
โอ้โหงั้นครูบีไปอยู่บ้านครูชิสัก 10 ปี
เสร็จแล้วครูบีก็ไล่ครูชิออกอย่างเงี้
เพราะครูบีอยู่มา 10 ปีอย่างงี้แรอคะ
โอ้โหคือมันมีกฎหมายที่เกี่ยวกับการครอบ
ครองไงแต่มากๆก็เป็นเรื่องของที่ดินไงใช่
ค่ะเออเป็นที่ดินว่างๆ้างแล้วแบบเป็นเจ้า
ของแล้วไม่ทำประโยชน์ใช่มั้ยอีกคนนึงมาทำ
ประโยชน์ปลูกนปลูกข้าวนะแล้วอยู่มาเป็น 10
10 ปีอันนี้โอเคอืเค้ามาขอเป็นเจ้าของ
ตรงนี้อ่าแต่อันนี้มันบ้านนะคะบ้านนี้คือ
ซื้อคือสร้างขึ้นมาเอ้อจะอยู่บ้านไม่อยู่
บ้านครูบีอาจจะไป
เอ่อซื้อไว้ที่กรุงเทพฯแล้วไปอยู่ที่
อีสานอ่า
กี่ปี 10 ปี 20 ปีครูบีไม่เคยมาอยู่แต่
มันก็เป็นบ้านครูบีที่ซื้อไว้ที่กรุงเทพฯ
แล้วครูชิจะเข้ามาอยู่แล้วบอกเป็นของูชิ
เี่มันไม่ได้ค่ะแล้วเเถียงเรื่องความเป็น
เจ้าของใช่มยเจ้าของบ้านไเจ้าของบ้านก็
เลยเข้า Google เลยเข้าไปดูแผนที่อ Google
สมัยปี 2000 เอ่อ 555
ตอนนี้ 6 ตอนนี้
2567 ใช่มั้ยค่ะย้อนกลับไปเป็น 10  12
ปีที่แล้วอ้าอืบ้านยังไม่มีใครมาบุกรุก
อืแต่มีของเนี่ยมาวางหน้าบ้านเหมือนกับ
บริษัทเยเริ่มมาวางของหน้าบ้านข้างบ้าน
แล้วค่อยๆมามาทำบ้านเ้าอ่ะครูบีเเนี่ยมา
ทำหลังคามาทำร้วบ้านใหม่โอูเค้ากล้าทำได้
ยังไงมันบ้านคนอื่นต่อให้ไม่มีเจ้าของมา
อยู่คือคุณไม่กลัวตำรวจจับคุณเลยเนาะคือ
แบบคุณคุณเป็นมากกว่าขโมยอีกนะคะเนี่ยคือ
บุกรุกบ้านคนอื่นแบบถึงขั้นทำหลังคาเลย
หรอูชิใช่ค่ะทำหลังคาข้างหน้าเนี่ยแล้วก็
ที่ตัดเนี่ยเพื่อเอาของมาเก็บไงเอาสีเอา
ท่ออะไรอ่ะ PVC เพราะว่าเค้าน่าจะเป็น
บริษัทก่อสร้างอ่ะเออแล้วก็เหมือนเอาของ
ที่ตัวเองขายเนี่ยมาเก็บที่บ้านคนอื่น
สบายฟรีไม่ต้องเช่าไม่ต้องจ่ายเงินโหมีคน
คิดแบบนี้ด้วยเหรอประเทศไทยอนั่นนสิเสร็จ
แล้วเนี่ยเค้าไม่ยอมเค้ากลับมาใหม่ค่ะมา
อยู่ใหม่ติดป้ายแล้วก็บอกว่าอันเนี้ยเค้า
เป็นเจ้าของแล้วนะเอาบ้านหลังเออบ้านหล
นี้
ทีเนี้ยท่านดูนะเค้าเคแบบเค้าย้ายของออก
ไปหมดแล้วเนี่ยแล้วเจ้าของบ้านเนี่ยไป
ล็อคประตูเนี่ยแสดงว่าเาไม่ได้ครอบครอง
ไม่ได้อยู่แล้วไงอืแล้วอยู่ๆก็เปลี่ยนใจ
กลับมาแล้วบอกว่าฉันไปเพราะว่าตกใจฉัน
กลับมาเพื่อแสดงว่าฉันยังเป็นคนอยู่ที่
เนี่ยติดต่อกัน 10 ปีแล้วอื
โอ้โหตั้งแต่ครูบีเกิดมาจนอายุ 18 นะครู
บีไม่เคยได้ยินคนบุกรุกบ้านแล้วบอกว่า
เป็นบ้านของตัวเองเลยค่ะอายุ 18 นะคะตอน
เนี้ยแล้วครูบีเห็นมั้ยถ้าเกิดเค้าเค้าเค
เอ่อจริงๆเคก็เหมือนกับเค้ารู้นะว่าเคทำ
ไม่ไม่ถูกอ่ะเพราะว่าเคคบอกเขาจะย้ายของ
ไปแล้วเก็ย้ายของออกไปเสร็จแล้วเปลี่ยนใจ
เอาย้ายกลับมาใหม่เพราะเขาคิดว่ามันมีกฎ
กฎหมายครอบครองที่ดินไงูชิเขาอาจจะไม่ได้
เข้าใจกฎหมายจริงๆแล้วคิดว่าเออฉันก็อยู่
มา 10 ปีฉันมีสิทธิ์ที่จะเอาบ้านหลังนี้
ได้เป็นเจ้าของได้แต่มันไม่ใช่ไอ้นี่มัน
เป็นบ้านมันไม่ใช่ที่ดิน
อืแล้วถือโอกาสไปตัดโซ่อะไรเค้าเนี่ย
ปรากฏว่าเจ้าของบ้านตอนนี้เขาไม่ยอมะอื
แล้วแล้วยิ่งพอตอนที่ไปไล่จำได้มั้ยปีที่
แล้วไปไล่เนี่ยขอซื้อบ้านอืแต่ขอซื้อใน
ราคาเมื่อแบบปี 3  34 ปีอุ๊ยสมัยไหนก็ไม่
รู้อ่ะอืนะคะปี 34 ตอนนี้ปี 67 อืบ้าน
เนี่ยมันก็ต้องขึ้นราคาใช่มั้ยใชถ้าคุณ
ซื้อตั้งแต่ปี
2534 อ่าก็ราคานี้แต่ปัจจุบันน่ะปี
2567 ใช่มั้ยก็ต้องเป็นราคาปัจจุบันอือ
แต่จะขอซื้อเมื่อ 30 ปีที่แล้วอ่ะราคา 30
เค้าก็ไม่ขายไงเ้ามีสิทธิ์ไม่ขายเ้าใครจะ
ขายจะบ้าเหรอูชิถ้าเจ้าของบ้านขายเนี่ย
เจ้าของบ้านก็บ้าเหมือนกัน
ค่ะแต่พอตอนเนี้ยตอนแรกเนี่ยคุณลุงที่ให้
บ้านเนี่ยก็บอกว่าอย่าไปทะเลาะกับเขาพูด
กับเขาดีๆให้เขาออกไปอืปรากฏว่าดูท่าทาง
แล้วจะคุยยากในที่สุดก็เลยดำเนินคดีค่ะ
แน่นอนค่ะเป็นครูบีก็จะดำเนินเินคดีแจ้ง
ความอ่าแจ้งตำรวจนะเพราะว่าเขาไม่ยอมไงเ
ไม่ยอมออกจากบ้านเราแถมมาตัดโซ่ด้วยเปิด
กุญแจเออไล่เจ้าของบ้านออกอีกจะเอาบ้านคน
อื่นเป็นบ้านของตัวเอง
โอ้โหอันนี้เขาก็เลยฟ้องบุกลุกค่ะอืบุก
ลุกเข้ามาในที่ของคนอื่นเสร็จแล้วที่เขา
มาตัดโซ่อ่ะมาตัดโซ่เนี่ยเขาก็โดนข้อหห
ทำลายทรัพย์อ่าแล้วที่มาสร้างอ่ะครูชิมา
สร้างหลังคานะครูบีจะเอาทุกข้อหาเลยใช่
อันนี้ทำให้พื้นที่ทำให้บ้านเราเสียหาย
ใช่เอมาต่อเติมบ้านเราโดยไม่ได้รับอนุญาต
อีกอืเอแล้วแถมยังเอาทรัพย์สินเราไปใช่
มั้ยเพราะว่าเรามีโซ่มีกุญแจล็อคไว้โซ่อ
กับกุญแจหายไปไหนแจ้งข้อหาลักทรัพย์ไป
ด้วยอืเอาทรัพย์สินของเราไปอ่าบุกรุกบ้าน
เราด้วยอ่าททำลายทรัพย์เราด้วยเออตัดโซ
บ้านเราอ่านะทำมารีโนเวทบ้านเราไม่ขอ
อนุญาตเนี่ยโอไม่เคยได้ยินเลยนะข่าวแบบ
นี้ครูชิครั้งแรกในชีวิตครูบีเลยที่แบบมา
บุกรุกบ้านคนอื่นแล้วจะเอาเป็นเจ้าของ
บ้านน่ะจะเอาบ้านคน
อื่นแล้วจะพยายามสู้ให้ชนะอีกอ่ะอืนะคโจะ
สู้ให้ชนะด้วยทุกคนก็พูดว่าคุณคิดได้
อย่างไรอืคือทุกคนคือโคอมเมนไงคือคิดว่า
คนเนี้ยที่มาบุกรุกบ้านเค้าเนี่ยคิดได้
ยังไงเออไม่มีใครคิดเนาะเหมือนที่ครูบี
บอกว่าบ้านร้าง 50 ปี 100 ปีเจ้าของบ้าน
อาจจะตายไปแล้วแต่ก็ยังไม่มีใครกล้าบุก
รุกเลยพะกลัว
ผีใช่มั้ยแล้วกูคิดดูดิถ้าเกิดคนที่เข้า
มาอยู่บ้านคนอื่นแล้วชนะอ่ะเออจะเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นจะมีคนหลายๆคนครูบีไม่อยู่บ้านครูชิ
จะแอบเข้าไปอยู่ในบ้านครูบี 10 ปีแล้วก็
บอกว่าฉันเป็นเจ้าของโอ้โหถ้าอย่างงี้ก็
ไม่ต้องซื้อบ้านไม่ต้องมีบ้านค่ะเออใช่
มั้ยมันไม่ได้ถ้ากฎหมายไม่คุ้มครองเจ้า
ของบ้านใช่มั้ยคะอ่าใช่มันเป็นไปไม่ได้
เจ้าของบ้านก็ต้องชนะอยู่แล้วนะคะอืมคือ
คือคือถ้าแพ้มาแบบนี้นะโอ้โหครูชิคิดว่า
ในในประเทศไทยหรือในสังคมไทยเนี่ยคุณมี
บ้านแล้วคุณไม่อยู่บ้านระวังมีคนเข้ามา
อยู่ในบ้านคุณแล้วก็จะได้เป็นเจ้าของด้วย
ออันนี้จะแย่มากใช่แต่ครูบีคิดว่าเป็นไป
ไม่ได้อยู่แล้วเนาะยังไงเจ้าของบ้านก็
ต้องชนะนะคะออเพราะว่ากฎหมายก็ไม่ได้บอก
ว่าเออไม่อยู่บ้าน 10 ปีมีคนแอบมาอยู่ถึง
10 ปีแล้วเอาเป็นบ้านของตัวเองได้โอ้โห
อย่างงี้ก็ไม่ต้องมีบ้านล่ะค่ะูบิจะไป
อยู่บนต้น
มะม่วงเป็นทาซานนะคะไปอยู่บนต้นไม้ดีกว่า
นะถ้างั้นน่ะเออแต่ถ้าเมื่อไหร่ปีลงจาก
ต้นมะม่วงจะมีคนมามาบุกลุกมาอยู่แล้วเป็น
เจ้าของต้นมะม่วงแทนครูบีนะคะไม่เป็นไร
เพราะครูบีก็าก้ายไปอยู่ต้นมะม่วงที่อื่น
เพราะมีต้นมะม่วงเยอะเอ้ออันนี้โอเคไม่มี
เจ้าของนะคะอยู่ในป่าเนี่ยแหละครูชิก็
เป็นข่าวที่โอครูชิเอามาเล่าแล้วครูบีก็
รู้สึกแบบไม่เคยได้ยินแล้วก็ไม่เคยเกิด
ขึ้นในประเทศไทยนะคะอืคือแล้วเรื่องแบบ
เนี้ยไม่ต้องต่อให้คนไม่รู้กฎหมายใช่ไม่
รู้เรื่องกฎหมายเนี่ยโดยความรู้สึกของคน
เราอ่ะเอ่อถ้าเค้าไม่ไม่ไม่อยากจะมีบ้าน
เค้าจะสร้างบ้านทำไมเค้าสร้างบ้านมาเสร็จ
เค้าซื้อบ้านเสร็จแล้วเค้าจะทิ้งบ้านหรอ
อืมหรือแมเค้าไม่มาอยู่ไม่ได้หมายถึงว่า
เขาจะทิ้งบ้านแล้วคุณจะเข้าไปเป็นเจ้าของ
บ้านที่เขาคทิ้งได้ไงโหก็บ้านที่ไม่มี
เจ้าของต่อให้เขาคทิ้งเราก็เข้าไปอยู่ไม่
ได้นะเออเดี๋ยวครอบครัวพี่น้องญาติใช่
มั้ยก็จะมาไล่เราออกไปนะคะคือมันเป็น
เบสิคมากเป็นเรื่องปกติที่เราต้องคิดใช่
มั้ยเออเราไม่มีสิทธิ์ไปบุกรุกบ้านคนอื่น
นะคะอืเราเราเรียกว่าคนทั่วๆไปหรือเรามี
คำพูดว่า
วิญญูชนคือคนทั่วๆไปเนี่ยเข้าใจได้อือว่า
อันเนี้ยมันผิดแน่ๆใช่ผิดตั้งแต่คุณไปทุบ
บ้านเขากำแพงเาแล้วก็เข้าไปทำอาหารเนี่ย
ค่ะโอ้โหคิดได้ยังไงคุณก็มีคุณทำอาหาร
บ้านตัวเองก็ได้ใช่มั้ยคะเออโอ้โหได้ยัง
ไงนั่นน่ะสิพยายามจะยึดบ้านเค้าเลยนะอยาก
จะเป็นเจ้าของบ้านเค้าให้ได้โอ้โหแต่ตอน
ตอนนี้เราก็ต้องต้องไปแล้วนะูชิเพราะว่า
เราจะยึดเวลาคนอื่นนะคะโอ้โหเหรอคะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยเราต้องมีคุณธรรมค่ะมีคุณธรรม
เข้าใจว่าอะไรถูกอะไรผิดเพราะฉะนั้นเราจะ
ไม่กินเวลาคนอื่นใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า
เดี๋ยวเราหมดเวลาแล้วเราต้องตรงเวลาแล้ว
ก็เราต้องให้เวลากับคนอื่นด้วยนะคะ
อ่าอก็วันนี้มาเล่าให้ฟังใช่ค่ะก็ขอบคุณ
ูชิมากเป็นเรื่องแปลกแล้วก็เป็นเรื่องที่
ทุกคนจะบอกคิดได้ยังไงใช่มั้อ่าแปลกแต่
เกิดขึ้นจริงแล้วในประเทศไทยค่ะวันนี้ก็
ต้องลานนักเรียนไปก่อนนะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะเอาไว้เจอกันใหม่นะคะครูชิ
ขอบคุณค่ะ